un 28 de diciembre que es día de los
inocentes en mexico y vamos a recibir
una llamada de la ciudad de mexico
yo tenía como unos 10 años
aproximadamente
ese día esa noche habían asaltado a mi
abuelo y le habían quitado la vida
mi abuelo era doctor en una colonia muy
modesta en el norte de la ciudad de
mexico
y bueno al siguiente día mis papás y mi
hermana se fueron al funeral y yo les
pedí a mis papás que me quería quedar en
monterrey siempre he sido una persona
muy visual y yo me quería quedar con la
imagen viva de mi abuelo
y mis papás aceptaron me dejaron
quedarme aquí creo que fue la primera
vez que
me dieron la oportunidad de ser quien yo
quería ser independientemente de las
reglas sociales de las de los rituales
que tenemos como sociedad
me queda aquí en monterrey y unos días
solo
cuando estaba ahí estaba pensando y
decía obviamente estaba muy triste y
estaba también como como más impotente
más que triste y decía lo que no puede
entender es cómo una sociedad como una
ciudad llega a ser
tan violenta para llegar a esos sucesos
creo que a los 10 años fue la primera
vez que me estrellé con un mundo que es
complejo
que es de alguna manera cruel y que es
deforme
diez años más tarde más o menos y con
muchos sacrificios que han hecho mis
papás voy a empezar a viajar a estudiar
fuera de mexico a conocer otras culturas
otras ciudades otras personas otras
formas de entender el mundo otras
religiones
y en estos viajes
fui descubriendo poco a poco que había
algunos espacios algunos objetos algunas
experiencias que me hacían sentir mejor
que otras
y poco a poco en estos viajes fue
encontrando el oficio de diseño
y decidí estudiar lo decidí comenzar mi
carrera en diseño
una de las cosas que me gusta de este
oficio que es muy noble es que conforme
voy haciendo mi trabajo puede ir como
moldeando el mundo que me gustaría tener
de alguna manera
[Música]
este es una doble ventaja que tengo
todos los días de hacer algo por lo que
me pagan pero además algo que lleva como
un poquito un poquito más allá a los 22
años más o menos fundé mi primera
compañía con unos amigos la hicimos en
esta casita en el centro de san pedro la
parte de abajo no nos alcanzaba para los
otros pisos
y ahí comenzamos a explorar estas nuevas
alternativas de lo que podríamos hacer
con el mundo poco a poco fui conociendo
más personas que
compartían los valores y las emociones
que yo tengo y fuimos asociándonos y
fuimos creciendo un poco transformando
nos poco a poco y hoy somos cinco
compañías creativas que se dedican a
crear valor para las organizaciones a
través de la creatividad aplicada y eso
se expresa en innovación en arquitectura
en diseño en comunicación en
cinematografía en minería de datos
conforme ha ido pasando el tiempo me ha
dado cuenta que hay tres principios que
me emociona mucho cuando sucede
son muy muy sencillos pero son difíciles
de encontrar
cabe mencionar que cuando estuve
viajando también muchas veces para
hacerlo es muy muy honesto me dio mucha
envidia de otras ciudades y de otros
lugares yo decía porque mi ciudad no es
barcelona porque mi ciudad no es parís
porque mi ciudadano es tokio porque mi
ciudad no es berlín
de repente me ha dado cuenta que esta
oportunidad de estar aquí
en una ciudad como esta me da el espacio
para ir creando poco a poco que quizás
no tendrían otros lugares
entonces los tres principios que les
quiero contar y son tres historias que
acompañan como estos principios es el
primero es simplicidad el segundo es
empatía y el tercero es belleza voy a
empezar por este
[Aplausos]
imagínense qué
este es uno de los principios que han
sido como los más difíciles de
evangelizar en esta ciudad porque es una
ciudad con herencia industrial donde lo
que importa es cuánto pesa algo cómo se
puede medir no se puede
tocar las cosas como físicas y un
concepto como la belleza que es un
es un concepto abstracto que nos puede
tocar es difícil de integrar una
sociedad que tiene una herencia digamos
como industrial pero imagina este caso
imagínense que llega conmigo o con
nosotros en la agencia una organización
de beneficiencia y nos dice oye quiere
digamos como cáritas oye queremos
recaudar fondos yo les digo excelente
hacemos algunas ideas y regresamos con
ellos y les decimos que tal si
contratamos un escultor renacentista
hacemos una fuente en el centro de la
ciudad y con eso te voy a recaudar un
millón y medio de euros
imagínense que mi consejo que está
tomando la decisión pues son ingenieros
industriales de toda la vida de acero
vidrio cemento que creen que me diría
probablemente estoy bastante loco
esta fuente no si la conocen yo tuve la
oportunidad de conocerla esta primavera
mi esposo me llevo
se llama la fuente de trevi en roma y si
usted es una fuente súper bonita para
mucha gente por ahí y hay una tradición
donde tú te sientas alrededor de la
fuente
te pones de espaldas y es un deseo a
viento es una moneda y se supone que
regreses a roma
total esta fuente que un rato y ahí en
roma literalmente recauda un millón y
medio de euros al año en monedas que
habían está la gente ahí lo que está
bien interesante de este fenómeno es
pensar
porque estoy recibiendo yo a cambio por
esa moneda que estoy dejando porque en
todo lo que hacemos en la vida cotidiana
siempre hay un intercambio de lo que yo
doy por lo que yo recibo y si se ponen a
pensar cuando ven tamos una moneda y
es simpático que estamos recibiendo por
un lado algo como mágico una
superstición de que vas a regresar allí
y probablemente por otro lado pues estás
dejando una moneda por el lugar que está
increíble porque además hay otras
fuentes en roma pero particularmente
esta es la fuente donde se recauda este
dinero al final lo que hace la iglesia
católica es va a recoger las monedas
cada cierto tiempo las buenas caritas y
cáritas se encarga de
esta hipótesis de que la belleza tiene
un cierto poder de tracción la hemos
estado probando poco a poco en la ciudad
con algunos clientes que son un poquito
más sensibles más visionarios y
trabajamos por ejemplo con uno de los
más importantes de la ciudad y hemos
estado diseñando su identidad visual y
la forma de expresarse en este es un
caso que retiramos al no se acuerdan
algunos de los que están aquí que antes
había unas lonas gigantes afuera del
museo las quitamos porque además son
bastante poco ecológicas y hemos
contratado unos
pintores para que nos hagan estos estos
murales y con un poco de intervenciones
gráficas hemos ido transformando poco a
poco la identidad del museo lo que está
padre de esto es después de un año
medimos que había pasado y resulta que
el número de visitantes pagados
que han asistido al museo en el último
año ha crecido como un 6 por ciento más
o menos
otro caso interesante por ejemplo
trabajamos con uno de los bancos también
más interesantes de la ciudad y hemos
sido también transformando la identidad
transformando sus visuales
yo estoy súper sorprendido porque hay
últimamente hicimos un proyecto con
ellos que es rediseño de unas tarjetas
de crédito que como nadie había puesto
atención ahí y realmente estaban todas
muy feas
lo que hicimos fue una colección muy
sencilla tarjetas de crédito que lo
único que tienen el principal factor
distinto que tienen es que tiene un
diseño digamos más bonito que las demás
y bueno lo lanzamos y resulta que hay
como 50.000 personas en lista de espera
para estas tarjetas
entonces parece ser que la belleza tiene
algo de tracción otro eje para bueno nos
decían los banqueros como más
tradicionales oye tú crees que alguien
se va a cambiar de banco la más porque
las tarjetas están más bonitas eso dice
la gente en twitter
otro caso que me gusta mucho es
trabajamos con este parque y rediseñamos
también su identidad y rediseñamos
algunas pequeñas cosas con un
presupuesto también muy modesto y lo que
sucedió también después de un año es que
el número de visitantes creció también
como un 7 por ciento que son 40.000
personas más que visitan la montaña
por ejemplo los ascensos a las cumbres a
los picos de la montaña antes tenían
como tres mil al año y ahora se sube
como 6000 personas y esto solo con el
cambio
de imagen pues al final parece que esta
hipótesis que la belleza tiene cierta
atracción pues es una cosa que es
interesante para mí y que me gusta estar
la como probando en ciertos proyectos en
ciertos casos el segundo caso es la
empatía y este me gusta mucho es un
proyecto que hicimos para el instituto
nacional de cancerología que es el
órgano rector del cáncer en mexico que
este es un hospital y un centro de
investigación que lo que hacen es tratar
enfermos oncológicos que no tienen
seguridad social total vinieron con
nosotros queremos hacer una campaña de
prevención detección temprana perfecto
lo vamos a hacer muy bien se nos ocurrió
una idea que se llama un minuto contra
el cáncer que básicamente eran
cápsulas con artistas y gente famosa
para hacer tips de detección temprana
todo funciona muy bien tuvimos mucha
atracción en internet todo perfecto pero
también nos dijeron oye queremos también
recaudar fondos y nuestro elegimos bueno
como imaginamos que puede ser esta
experiencia de donación nos dijeron pues
hagamos la como todo el mundo lo hace
abramos una cuenta de banco y que la
gente venga y nos dona dinero
y nos dijo le hace cuánto que no vas tú
al banco para tus propias cosas cómo
crees que va a ir gente para otras cosas
de terceros total se enojaron con
nosotros nosotros con ellos y así salió
la campaña
después de seis meses cuanto a las
personas creen que fueron a donar al
banco
fueron dos personas
regresaron con nosotros bueno quizás si
hay que repensar la forma de donar ok y
total en una de las visitas que hemos
hecho en el hospital esta es una de las
salas de quimioterapia del hospital
donde la gente que está ahí recibiendo
tratamiento tiene unas televisiones que
les ponen películas
y dijimos bueno qué podríamos hacer para
hacer la experiencia de donación un
poquito más atractiva también para
ponernos en los zapatos de la persona
que lo va a hacer y resulta que
encontramos una tecnología que está un
poco moribunda y que se utiliza para
cosas bastante
[Música]
interesantes como chats eróticos y
horóscopos y cosas así y resulta que es
los mensajes de texto pero esta
tecnología que ya está muriendo resulta
que es una de las pocas tecnologías que
está monetizada entonces lo que hicimos
fue qué pasaría si pudiéramos abrir un
canal de comunicación directo desde tu
teléfono hasta las pantallas del
hospital y lo que hicimos fue una
campaña donde mandaba un mensaje de
texto de aliento a las personas que
estaban en el hospital y además parte
del costo de tu mensaje se donaba
instantáneamente el hospital hicimos
este vídeo para lanzarlo
mi nombre es rocío tengo 47 años y tengo
cáncer
apoya a pacientes con cáncer enviando un
mensaje de texto que inicie con la
palabra ánimo al 3 12 12 ellos podrán
leerlo en tiempo real y además donar as
parte del costo de tu mensaje para
seguir tratando a miles de mexicanos un
minuto con tristeza pues resulta que
lanzamos este pequeño anuncio ya sin
dinero ya nos habíamos gastado todo el
presupuesto le pedimos amigos que nos
ayudan a filmar gratis etcétera lo
lanzamos y en menos de tres meses las
personas que están en esta sala de
quimioterapia recibieron 15.000 mensajes
de aliento desde chiapas hasta tijuana y
te raro de pensar que
sobre mí lo que me gusta esta idea es
parece ser que no es como que antes de
esta idea la gente en méxico era
bondadosa y después de éste no era
bondadosa y después de esta idea sí sino
que realmente sucedió algo de ponernos
en los zapatos no solo de las personas a
las que vamos a ayudar sino también de
las personas que iban a ayudar y esa
capacidad de ponerte en los zapatos de
varias personas al mismo tiempo cuando
está resolviendo un problema lo que me
gusta de esta dimensión de empatía que
es difícil de hacer pero hay que estar
como dispuestos a vivir y sufrir el
problema
y eso es un poco lo que me gusta de la
empatía la tercera idea más bien el
tercer principio que es muy personal y
también lo llevo mucho mi trabajo es la
simplicidad y lo que sucede con con esta
dimensión es que hay ciertos tipos de
ideas que son muy difíciles de encontrar
pero que cuando las encuentras resuelven
un montón de cosas de una manera muy
elegante y muy sencilla y muy simple
entonces esta es una idea que no hemos
hecho que me encantaría que sucediera en
esta ciudad y se las quiero compartir y
quiero que me van a compartir sela para
hacérsela llegar a quien tenga que
escucharla pero bueno resulta que esta
idea no lo encontramos casi de manera
accidental resulta que estábamos
haciendo una investigación de campo en
las farmacias y yo pues estaba ahí
platicando con el dependiente y le decía
oye jose tú que trabajas aquí éste está
platicando con el higo donde vives
estamos en la colonia y dice no pues yo
vivo en la colonia zeta
ok como es más o menos tu día a día no
me dice pues mira a mí yo me tardó dos
horas en ir a mi trabajo dos horas en
regresar me gasto como 90 pesos más o
menos en transporte público y me gasto
como 75 pesos en comida porque no puedo
comer en mi casa
entonces yo le decía oye y no hay una
farmacia en la colonia acepta donde tú
vives no sé si hay una formación
y yo porque no trabajas allá como
quien decide cómo trabajas tan lejos mi
seno pues es una cosa que es un poco
aleatoria no hay unas reglas claras de
cómo funciona etcétera entonces lo que
hicimos fue calcular qué pasaría si jose
trabajara ni siquiera tan cerca de su
casa a la mitad de la distancia de donde
trabaja hoy y resulta que josé si
hiciera esto
hicimos el cálculo y en tiempo de
transporte se ahorraría 200 600 24 horas
que equivale a 26 días con su familia
y resulta también que en economía podría
ahorrar son 237 mil pesos de lo que se
gasta en transporte público para tenerlo
en navidad al final del año
lo que está más interesante de esto es
que hay siete mil farmacias en mexico y
hay unas 25.000 tiendas de conveniencia
y estos dos formatos de marca o de
tienda pues trabajan mucho con la
conveniencia pero es interesante pensar
es conveniente para quien compra lo
también debería ser conveniente para
quien trabaja allí
si fuéramos como un poco más
consistentes en la en la oferta de valor
entonces lo que hicimos es que pasaría
un cálculo
si de estas siete mil farmacias y estos
25 mil tiendas de conveniencia
lográramos reeducar a una persona a la
mitad de la distancia de donde trabaja
resulta que ahorraríamos para economía
familiar mil 230 millones de pesos en
una
para las familias
y también conseguiríamos 20 millones de
horas de tiempo familiar
además podríamos tener menos tráfico
vehicular la ciudad tendríamos mejor
calidad del aire
probablemente también reduciríamos el
riesgo de traslado de las mujeres
estarse trasladando tanto tiempo de su
casa a su trabajo
y probablemente también las empresas
tendrían el beneficio de tener menor
rotación y gente como un poco más
contenta en sus lugares de trabajo al
final esto
pues nos da un poco una sensación de una
mejor ciudad
esto es lo que les quiero pedir bueno
perdón y lo que lo que más me gusta de
esta idea lo que más más me gusta de
esta idea es que esta idea está en manos
de seis personas
los seis directores de recursos humanos
de las cuatro farmacias más importantes
de méxico y los dos
las dos cadenas de tiendas de
conveniencia todo lo que les quiero
pedir que me ayuden a que esta idea les
llegue a ellos ya sea ellos a estos
directores de recursos humanos oa los
hijos
al final
no se necesita una nueva app
no necesitamos inteligencia artificial
no necesitamos innovación
no necesitamos diseño para hacer esto lo
único que se necesita es voluntad
al final lo que yo quiero hacer en mi
carrera y en mi vida es crear un mundo
mejor
quiero crear si yo tengo hijos después
concitado y después tenemos nietos
quiero crear un mundo más simple más
empático y más bello
en el que vivió mi abuelo muchas veces
[Aplausos]